[Music]
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us
it's films like these that IMAX really
shines
ready higher further faster famous
captain marvelous sex before any of the
events that happened in the MCU so
you're free race and noble warriors
heroes noble warrior heroes we get to
introduce Captain Marvel who's one of
the most powerful superheroes she
doesn't know her own past over the
course the movie you get to uncover that
with her and then you get to see what
her origin really is and how she became
who she is it's the combination of her
humanity and strength that really drew
me to it you've never shot anything like
this before
superhero movie where IMAX movie and so
to get them both all in one package
she's gonna be fantastic and I think
it's a special movie going experience
the technological advances that continue
to happen we're getting immersed in a
real-life honest and off the chain count
away you're gonna be like in space
you're seeing giant ships there's more
of the negative that you're not seeing
in the regular movie theater IMAX always
give you this otherworldly type
experience you get to explore more of
space with Captain Marvel just to open
up that screen and get the full scope of
what's going on describe this film in
IMAX in three words higher further
faster power resilience truth you just
want to be fully immersed a full blown
multi-sensory experience there's the
movie and then of you actually feeling
like in the movie I think those are
gonna be really powerful images to see
on a giant screen
try to keep up
I need to see it at either
you